hello everyone welcome back to the
channel uh today I am absolutely honored
and proud to announce that uh we finally
surpassed 25,000 subscribers uh it's
been about two years of work getting to
this point and I'm very proud of that uh
also especially far more proud for all
of you who have actually gotten good
results out of watching the videos on
here uh which at the end of the day is a
lot more important to me than any
subscriber count um I'm going to keep
this thing pretty short and sweet mainly
because I ate a bunch of chili at my
works happy hour and uh if I take too
long uh to make this video I'm going to
have to poop in the middle of it so
let's hope that doesn't happen um I
really thought this video was kind of
going to be a wash I was like oh Reddit
comments you know that should be
relatively easy and then um I spent the
next few days trying to figure it out
because it turns out it's not that easy
so uh let's go ahead and talk about it
all righty let's see if I can get
through this video relatively fast I am
uh feing for an edible here it is a
Friday night and I'm tired so what are
Reddit comments well technically in this
series alone I've already made another
video devoted to this and that is true
it was in the Twitter video however I
don't really think I went in nearly as
much depth here as I could have and uh I
would like to try and cover all my bases
in this 2.0 serious so let's go ahead
and do that so if you're not a big redit
user like myself because I have no life
uh this is somewhat what it looks like
you'll have your post at the top uh you
know for example I just reach 25k that's
worthy of a post and then we've got some
comments and the interesting thing about
comments is they can actually just be
infinitely nested within one another so
for example here we have Sydney
Sweeney she's uh she's okay looking and
she's calling me sexy 100 up votes
everyone agrees with her Kate Upton
calls me smart she's responding to
Sydney Sweeny and then Mark cucker BG
says lies um munis on the other hand is
uh also agreeing with Sydney Sweeney and
says take my up vote and you can see we
have these up vote and down vote counts
over here which is another very
important part of Reddit so actually
here are our formal problem requirements
because just the nesting of the comments
itself is not so important but actually
Reddit is going to support a bunch of
different ways of viewing the comments
with on a within a given post so the
first is going to be new which is
basically like think of all of these um
types of defining comment orders as
hierarchical so basically first we would
order all of the top level comments by
the newest ones and then you know when
we're showing now the second comment or
like the second layer of comments within
a top level comment we're also ordering
those by the newest one so hopefully
that makes sense right I'm going to pick
the newest out of all the top level and
then within one comment when I'm looking
at the chain of comments that are
responding to that I also pick the
newest there and then on and on and on
and on then we have hot which is
basically you know let's say within the
last hour or so what's gotten the most
up votes we've got top what's gotten the
most up votes in the entire history of
the post and also controversial which is
some factor or some calculation based on
the number of up votes the number of
down votes the number of total
interactions and basically you know
probably a lot of up votes and a lot of
down votes totaling somewhere near zero
so like I mentioned all of these are
recursive right so you know not only do
I want you know the newest post at the
top second newest
Etc but also within this guy I now want
the newest at the top the second newest
over here and then within this guy I
also want the newest at the top second
newest over here so hopefully that makes
sense it's all recursive at least that's
how I'm choosing to implement it for
this problem Reddit of course can change
things up as they
please great so the next thing we're
going to do are some very brief capacity
estimates so that is actually going to
be pretty relevant for this problem
because if in theory our posts or the
number of comments on a post is you know
boundless and you know you can have
literally billions of comments and
billions of inner comments on that post
well we're not going to be able to put
everything on a single partition and
then we're probably going to be in a lot
of trouble in terms of scaling this
thing out so let's go ahead and actually
do some quick mental math to try and
figure out whether single partitioning
per post at least is possible so I did
some quick Googling and apparently there
are 500,000 comments on the most popular
Reddit thread ever but since we're not
soft over here we're going to round up
to a million and double that the next
thing that we're going to do is I'm
going to assume uh that the average
comment size is around 200 characters in
length now that is probably going to be
the majority of storage that we need to
store a comment however there is going
to be some other metadata like a user ID
a post ID the time of the comment the
number of cumulative up votes or down
votes stuff like that so I'm actually
going to imagine that every single
comment is going to take around 500
bytes to store in total cool so that
means that for a single post if we just
wanted to store all of the raw comments
on it that we could probably get away
with doing so using 500 megabytes of
data now the nice thing about that is
that is not a lot we can definitely get
that on a single hard drive or within a
single partition and and if we decided
for whatever reason to completely copy
all of those for our four in total
comment views that could be 2 GB of
total storage and in theory if we were
able to keep those all on the same
actual database node that could benef uh
benefit us in many ways as well we might
be able to avoid a two-phase commit if
we were writing to all four of those at
a time so like I mentioned it's likely
going to be possible to store these on a
single partition which is huge for us
we'll still discuss what would happen if
we couldn't but uh yes I think
reasonably we can make that assumption
and then another thing is that let's uh
assume that rather than denormalizing
our data right making four different
copies for all of those four views we
decided to normalize it so we had one
source of Truth View and then three
secondary indexes that only included the
comment IDs and their ordering in that
case if we just needed the comment IDs
it's probably going to be about eight
bytes to store an ID right 64 bits or
something like that or a long and then
again there might be up to a million
comments per post so now 8 megabytes and
the nice thing about 8 megabytes is
that's not not a lot of data at all we
could probably store that in memory but
we'll also cross that bridge when we get
there cool so let's think about some
main considerations for this problem to
also help us prioritize you know what
type of data flow we're trying to
optimize here because it's Reddit uh the
majority of people are probably lurking
there are posts with a lot of comments
but I would say that even more so than
that most people are actually just
reading and not commenting and so again
if reads are going to happen much more
frequently than writes we do want to be
prioritizing the read path that doesn't
mean that people don't comment at all if
we do have a comment I don't want
someone waiting you know 10 to 30
seconds for their comment to show up it
should show up relatively quickly but at
the end of the day if it is like a very
clear choice between our read speeds and
our right speeds we should probably
optimize for reads cool like I mentioned
we don't want really bad rights and then
the biggest thing which is going to
become very important later on is that
even though we have four different
comment views they don't actually have
to be perfectly in sync as long as
they're probably eventually consistent
with one another right so the idea is
you know imagine we had our new view and
it's showing that there's comment three
one and two and then the top view shows
that there's comments you know four one
and two that's actually not a huge deal
as long as eventually they're both going
to be showing the same thing we don't
necessarily have to basically commit a
comment to all four views at the same
time we can deal with some lag there a
user isn't really going to know and even
if they did it's social media they're
not going to care that much one thing
that is particularly important though is
that all of these views are going to be
causally consistent so that the comments
actually makes sense so when I say
causal consistency it means that if you
have one comment uh that is being
displayed on your screen and it relies
on some parent comment that the parent
comment is also present right so I can't
have comment two over here without
comment one existing if this guy weren't
able to be here and we just saw a
comment to everyone would be like well
why does this even exist what's it
replying to and that would become
confusing so we do want to maintain
causal consistency across all of our
views cool so the first thing that I'm
going to touch upon now is this concept
of a source of truth table so like I
mentioned regardless if we of whether we
have four different copies of all the
comments or whether we have one source
of truth table and you know three
different secondary indexes we are going
to need basically one centralized data
store where we can rely on the data and
say like these are actually our comments
for the Post right this is not
eventually consistent this this is it
right here cool so again the interesting
thing with comments and Reddit are that
they are organized as some sort of tree
so as you can see right here if we have
a post here's some top level comments
maybe those have children maybe their
children might even have children and so
generally we're almost thinking about
this thing as like a big tree or
possibly even a graph I wouldn't say
it's a graph it is technically a tree
but I guess all trees are graphs so you
can say that cool so the first thing
that we're going to talk about is how
we're going to build out this you know
just generic commenting table or what
I'm going to call the source of truth
table so I'd say we have two main
options the first is going to be
actually using a graph database cuz like
I mentioned trees are graphs and so the
nice thing about graph databases are
that they're good at handling this data
the reason being that you actually use
physical pointers on your hard drive
from node to node this is in contrast to
something like a non-native graph
database where we basically just use a
typical relational database index in
order to abstract away the concept of
the edge right so I would basically have
a second table that represents an edge
where I would have the primary IDs of
the two nodes that are being connected
the problem with that is that as that
table uh our edges table grows in size
the slower it is to actually find an
edge because indexes grow
logarithmically relative to the size of
the table and so non-native graph
databases are sometimes not so great
however in contrast a native graph
database is not going to get any slower
as the table itself gets bigger so like
I mentioned internally basically if I
have you know some post right here we're
also going to maintain a list of all the
edge objects which again would just be
some address on disk and then we can
jump to those in O of one time now do
note that uh just because we're jumping
in O of one time doesn't mean that
constant factor is fast right jumping
from place to place on disk objectively
is pretty slow you have to scan all over
the disk and so for this reason ideally
if you can avoid using a graph database
you might want to it's also sometimes
pretty hard to scale them out if your
data has to live on multiple different
partitions uh but ideally we can keep
all of our data on one partition here as
we discussed
so the way that we could kind of easily
abstract things away here is if we have
a post and then we have a comment right
so I can give all of my edges uh
increasing alphabetical sequences so a
for the first Edge B for the second and
then what we would do then is give each
child Edge another letter a and b so
this way I know if you know I want to go
to comment a I can really really quickly
get there uh basically linearly to the
length of the ID of the node I would
just say first jump to a then jump to to
be and that's a lot better than having
to run some sort of like depth for
search every single time to actually
find your comment cool and if you're
actually thinking about this what's
interesting is that the way that this
graph works is that it's actually going
to preserve the order that the nodes
were written right so if I were to load
this entire graph this is effectively
the same as our new configuration for
comments because the first thing that's
going to come up is a the next thing
that's going to come up is B and we said
that the reason B is B is because it was
added after a we just added one letter
to a and so now we have B so this guy
obviously came in after a so it's
older or rather actually it's newer this
is going apologies this is going to be
the exact reverse of our new index but
it's kind of the same concept here where
you would just load it in reverse so no
big deal you would just read backwards
through the edges list to get your new
index cool and then similarly the same
exact thing is happening recursively
right over here so if I actually look at
these two children nodes over here I
know that
AB is
newer than
AA and that's going to really quickly
allow us to figure out the newest
comments per comment even cool the next
option to build this base table out is
instead of just doing it using a graph
database we can actually use a normal
database so this is the solution that I
touched upon a lot more in that kind of
Twitter and Reddit video and the main
idea here is we can actually just use a
generic index since this isn't a full
graph and it's effectively just a tree
we can very much smartly organize our
nodes via Smart naming in order to
properly uh put them down in an index
and find nodes easily so how would this
work let's imagine we have this root
node and it's got the ID of a well its
first child is going to be given the
same exact prefix of its parent so in
this this case a and then since it's the
first child we're going to add a the
second child is going to have the same
prefix as the parent a and then we're
going to add B and we can do the same
exact thing in the children of children
so we start again with the prefix equal
to the parents ID and then add a and
then we do the same exact thing over
here oh wait second child now we add B
and so the idea now is that if you
recall an index in a traditional
database is really just sorting out the
data right so all of a sudden if we sort
these things in alphabetical order we
get ourselves with this data right here
and so now it actually becomes really
really easy to do like a typical depth
first search because if I say you know I
want this entire tree of comments right
here all I have to do is run a range
query on our index from a through a a
and we get really really nice data
locality because they're all next to one
another on disk and then of course you
might be thinking to yourself well
Jordan you know there actually going to
be a lot more comments than 26 per level
you probably can't just do a through z
you're right I probably can't uh but if
I did do 0 through 9 and a through z
that would give me 36 combinations if I
did four of those per level so instead
of being a this guy could be like you
know 9 B D7 or something like that uh
that would allow us 36 combinations uh
to the fourth which is 1.7 million
combinations per level and then for
example its first child would be like 9
b d 7 uh c z uh 12 or something like
that where you would you know keep the
parents uh prefix and then you would go
ahead and append something new cool so
hopefully that makes sense and if you
notice this again like the graph
database is going to maintain that new
ordering naturally because we basically
just do uh the reverse of the traversal
right so AB we know is newer than AA
aab is newer than AAA and so we can
really easily go down recursively and
basically figure out uh what the newest
comment is at each level pull that and
then pull whatever children it has or
the first newest children of it cool
hopefully that makes sense thus far so
basically by just building out this what
I would call source of truth table we
already have a really good index for
quickly returning the newest comments
back to our users so that's kind of
already handled for us
so now the question is well we've
provided two possible approaches we've
provided the graph database approach and
we've also provided the relational
database approach which should we
actually go ahead and use so the nice
thing about our relational database like
I mentioned is that just going back up a
slide if we wanted to do a depth first
search on this guy it's super easy
because everything that is actually um a
child is right next to its parent right
this guy is a child child of this guy
which is a child of this guy this guy is
a child of this guy which is a child of
this guy and so you get really nice data
locality doing depth first searches on
the contrary if for whatever reason I
wanted to do a breath first
search basically I start here and then I
go here and then I go here all of a
sudden we're jumping around quite a bit
on our Index right I have to go here and
then I have to go here and obviously the
more nodes there are in the graph the
worse that's going to get and then all
of a sudden your index doesn't actually
help you out very much so I would say
this if you definitely know that you're
only going to be doing uh depth first
type of queries the relational index
that I built is going to help a lot if
you want to be able to do generalizable
queries well maybe it might not be so
good now if you're recall like I
mentioned graph databases are not going
to be that fast in absolute terms
because of the fact that you're jumping
around disc all the time right you don't
get good data locality it's still 0 of
one time to find your next node but it
takes a long time time to actually go to
that actual address on disk so if we're
just doing breath for search I would say
or uh sorry a depth for search I would
say we should stick to our non-graph
database but if we want to be able to do
uh basically arbitrary queries I think
the graph database is going to be our
move cool and then of course you know
take this all with a grain of salt you
have to Benchmark in reality look at
your actual use cases and then come back
to me uh nothing that I say here
actually has a good amount of data to
back it up this is all purely
theoretical cool so we've now spoken
about how we would build a new index for
comments let's talk about our top index
so like I mentioned top comments are
those that are sorted by the most
upvotes at every single level right and
the idea here is that well you know if
we wanted to actually use a typical
index we could do that in absolute terms
right so we could very easily build an
index to show us the top comments across
all comments but to do so at every
single level of our graph right is not
easy because then I would have to
basically you know let's say we've got
three top level
comments somehow we'd have to build a
bunch of different indices right we'd
have to build one index for just these
guys and then separately another index
for these guys another index for these
guys another index for these guys that
doesn't work it's too many indexes it's
just it doesn't scale properly so it
doesn't make a lot of sense so what
actually are going to be our options
here well for one we could basically a
just you know remake the data but then
use a different graph database and also
uh you know just have this be for the
top comments and then the other option
is to basically keep a secondary index
over just the comment IDs and like I
specified before we would do that in
memory because if it's just the IDS uh
we mentioned that was around 8 megabytes
of storage that is very very easy to
keep in megabytes uh in memory God as
you can see I'm very tired and so if we
keep that whole thing in memory we can
quickly query it and then go back to our
source of truth table and get all of the
comments that we
want so I've said that very abstractly
let's go ahead and take a look at how it
would actually work in
practice so let's imagine that we wanted
a graph database for top comments
specifically so the idea is you know if
I have this uh Main comment right here
so comment
one and now it's got three children
comments 1 2 and three the idea is we
want our edges to be ordered by the
number of upvotes that each of those
child comments has so that we're making
sure that we pull them in in the right
order this is going to allow us to make
faster reads if they weren't in the
right order we could write really
quickly to this graph however when it
came time to read every single read
query would have to basically sort all
of these edges 12 6 and -2
and that would be bad because if they
were unsorted now all of a sudden you're
having to do an N log n sort over the
number of child comments which can be
slow cool so ideally we want to do most
of the work on the right path so just
going over here how would this actually
look a Right comes
in let's say all of a sudden I just
added seven upvotes to this guy so now
instead of being at six it's going to be
at
positive3 now what we would actually
want to do is reorder our edges list
from comment one which previously had
let's call these guys a b and c so
previously we said okay you know the
first comment you want to show from
comment one is a then you want to show B
then you want to show C oh wait now all
of a sudden B has more up votes than C
or rather than a so let's go ahead and
modify this thing so that it's b a c
because now this guy is the most popular
and that way we make sure that you know
if we're ever just looking for the top
comment of comment one that we're just
going to be grabbing b as opposed to a
cool and then we have to do that same
thing on every single write process so
for whatever reason I were to write to
this guy and add seven over here and
let's call this guy I don't know ba and
BB previously the order of edges was
ba and
BB now however BB is actually more
popular so it's going to go BB ba a cool
hopefully that makes enough sense there
the point is you're doing a little bit
of extra work on the right path
maintaining your sorted list of edges on
every single right so that when it comes
time to read you can just go ahead and
grab those edges properly without having
to actually sort all of them this is
good especially when you have limit
queries because it means that you're not
going to have to go through the whole
list and sort
it cool so that is the option where we B
basically effectively maintain a full uh
graph of comments in a secondary graph
database where the data is denormalized
in the second option we can actually
just do so in a normalized manner where
rather than holding the whole graph on
disk we actually hold the whole graph in
memory but it's just the IDS right so
like I mentioned you know in theory in
this approach I would actually have the
comment associated with each of these
like
Jordan you're
handsome and it's going to be stored
right
there but in this guy it would just be
hey you know this is IDC over here and
then let's say I decide that c is the
top comment I'm going to go over to the
database and say hey get me those rights
in particular and fetch them and so in
that sense we do actually add some
additional read latency right because of
the fact that you know now I have to do
an additional join on this database data
and so we have to get one other Noe
involved uh that being said uh another
thing to note is that this potentially
makes more sense if our source of Truth
database is the graph database as
opposed to the relational one because
the um top comments that we're getting
back are not necessarily going to be in
a perfect uh depth first search
configuration that would work well with
our uh relational database it's probably
going to be relatively arbitrary which
comments within a chain are the top ones
and so as a result of that we want to be
running arbitrary uh queries over our
source of Truth database it would be
better if it were a graph database cool
so the idea mainly here is that we're
going to do quite literally the same
exact thing as over here right where we
tape in a write we reorder the edges so
that we have uh you know faster reads
every single time that we want to find
the top comments the one additional
optimization that you could in theory
make though is that because this is
going to be in memory we can actually
add an additional hashmap right so now
we actually have the ID of a node and
it's corresponding Edge so that we can
quickly increment the count there so
let's say this guy had uh you know 20 up
votes and this guy had 15 and this guy
had 10 in the graph database scenario we
would actually have to Traverse the
graph and find this particular Edge to
increment the number associated with it
in the inmemory situation when we make a
write and uh include an upvote what we
can actually do is keep a hashmap from
you know the edge of the node or rather
the the ID of the node to the edge
itself and then we can just go ahead and
add to that
number cool hope that makes sense uh
it's kind of useful that we have that
because otherwise rights can take a
really long time you know if I'm 10
layers deep in the comment change and
I'm trying to add 10 to it traversing
through the graph and finding that is
actually going to be somewhat
expensive the next thing to talk about
is going to be controversial comments so
the fortunate thing here is as far as
controversial comments go there isn't
actually much to talk about the one
thing to talk about is what is a
controversial comment well I'm not going
to go for any sort of explicit
definition here but the main idea is a
controversial comment is one where
there's a lot of up votes and there's a
lot of down votes such that you know
when you add up the sum of the two that
the total score of the comment is close
to zero so I came up with some
completely bogus formula right here that
could in theory calculate it kind of
well because also in addition to just
having a total close to zero you want to
make sure that there were actually a lot
of up votes and a lot of down votes on
that comment so here's my bogus
formula I'm sure at least one or two of
you comment Warriors going to be like oh
but then if the number of up votes minus
the down votes is equal to zero you know
you're not going to have a number which
is why I wrote that note right there so
I thought of you buddy um but yeah the
idea basically is that we want to be
doing the same thing you know we
generate some controversial score
from our up votes and our down boats and
we do that on all
edges and then as our controversial
score updates maybe this guy becomes
more controversial you know this guy all
of a sudden becomes more controversial
than this guy now guess what we have to
flip
them so that this guy is the first Edge
that we Traverse to so again the idea is
mainly just update the weights on the
edges do the work on the right path to
reorder edges list so that we Traverse
the proper nodes uh in the right order
and then we do less work on the read
path and it's the same exact thing here
as the top comments we have two options
again we can have a fully separate graph
database or we can have a normalized
inmemory graph index of all of the
comment IDs uh in you know in the
correct controversial ordering and then
once we actually get the comment IDs
that we want to fetch we can go right
back to our source of Truth graph
database Traverse it as necessary and
get all of the comments that we need
cool so the next part of this that I'm
going to touch upon is actually going to
be hot comments so unlike the other
types of comments that I've spoken about
before hot comments are a little bit
more complex uh the reason being that
the idea here is that hot comments have
had a lot of upvotes in the last X
minutes or maybe hour or something like
that and so the idea is that we're going
to have to deploy a separate component
or a separate piece of functionality
that is ultimately going to keep track
of when an upvote you know it's been an
hour and now that upvote is no longer
hot and so we have to take it away from
that comment hopefully that makes sense
the idea is you know I attribute the up
vote to your comment for a bit an hour
passes guess what that up vote no longer
matters this is no longer a hot up vote
so we can get rid of it and so
fortunately this is a pattern that we've
seen plenty on this channel before it's
effectively just a sliding window right
so it's a sliding window with a size of
X minutes and so that all we really have
to do is as up votes come in first we
can just buffer them in something like
Kafka that way we can use a stateful
consumer like Flink the reason I say use
a stateful consumer is that we're
maintaining state if it goes down we
don't want to lose it right we do want
to eventually be sure to decrement those
upvotes again so it' be great to use
something that is fall tolerant like
Flink where a checkpoints at State on
occasion to S3 and that is going to be
maintaining a linked list and the linked
list is going to allow us to really
really easily maintain that sliding
window so as an element comes in we add
it to the back of our link list we add
an upvote to the comment that it's
relevant for on the other hand we'll
also have to check to see if the head of
our length list has been expired right
we've got a time stamp at each of these
points and so we can see if it's been an
hour if it has I remove it from the link
list I go and take the comment ID
associated with that element of the link
list and then I subtract an upvote from
the database so what actually is going
on over here in this database well funny
enough it can be literally the same
exact thing that we did for both our top
and our controversial comments which is
either a a completely full copy of the
graph database but just you know
organized such that we prioritize hot
comments or the other option is that we
do again the inmemory index of just the
comment
IDs cool so hopefully that makes sense
about how we would go ahead an expire an
up Vote or an expire a down vote notice
how I said plus one up vote and minus
one up vote here if it was a down vote
that was incoming it would actually be
minus one over here and plus one over
here cool now the next part of this is
we've basically discussed how we want to
go ahead and model our data uh per
comment type however how are we actually
going to get the data over to all of
those different indexes or those
replicas of the graph database do we
want to do do it synchronously meaning
when I write a comment should it go to
all four of them or should we do it in a
derived manner which is I write a
comment it goes to one place and then
eventually we put it everywhere
else well the first question is should
we do it synchronously my answer as pre
usual is no we probably shouldn't why is
that well for starters it may require a
two-phase commit it's hard to guarantee
that all of these guys all these four
different tables are going to be on the
same physical node we could probably do
it uh but but then now all of a sudden
we have to store more data there and so
even if we did do that uh it could be
slow in terms of contention right we
have to wait for all of those
transactions to go through it involves
grabbing a lot of locks and the bigger
thing is that like I mentioned uh I
mentioned this kind of towards the
beginning of the video we don't actually
need to keep all four of these views
perfectly consistent it doesn't really
matter as long as they're eventually
consistent right as long as they'll
catch up to one another and as long as
each individually is causally consistent
we should be good to go so the next
thing I'm going to touch on quickly is
okay we're going to do some form of
derived data but before we even do any
of that how can we actually make sure
that we keep all of these views causally
consistent and then we'll talk about
eventual
consistency cool so the question first
is what is causal consistency now if
you've been watching this channel long
enough you probably know by now uh but
let's go ahead and lay it out so the
first thing is that again like I covered
before if you add a comment to a table
its parent needs to exist if I add this
guy over here and there's no comment for
this guy even though it exists in some
other table uh we're going to be like
WTF the user is not going to understand
what's happening the database is going
to throw a fit it's not going to be good
so we want to avoid that the next thing
is that well if an up Vote or a down
vote were to come in the comment on it
right so if I up vote a comment on my
client and then I send that up vote to
one of my databases of which there could
be many the comment that I uploaded
needs to exist if it doesn't that's not
going to make a lot of sense our
database is going to throw a fit so
again if we just have comment a over
here and then we see plus one on comment
B that would be
bad cool so what are a couple of
different options that we could do I'm
going to cover three of them the reason
being that I first covered two thought
that was good realized they weren't good
and I was like oh wait here's a third
solution that works much better so we're
going to cover the first two discuss why
they're bad and then do the third cool
so the first two are these we could
basically put every single incoming
comment every single incoming up vote
and every single incoming down vote on
the same Kafka Q sharded by our post ID
why does this work well for starters the
nice thing about Kofa Q's is that they
only have a single consumer and they are
completely ordered and so as a result of
that if I have a comment that exists
such that you can uh you know make a
child comment of it or you can upload it
I know that that comment will be in the
kofka que before your child comment or
before your upload of that one and so
the nice thing about that is that then I
don't have to worry about causal
consistency the problem there is that
that probably works fine for the
comments alone there can be a lot of up
votes and down votes if you think about
it there are comments that have
thousands of up votes and down votes and
there can be thousands of comments which
means there can be millions of up votes
and down votes for a single post and
that could potentially overwhelm our
single cofaq so what could we actually
do differently there well one option
would be that we basically take all of
our new comments we write them
synchronously to all four of our comment
views and then from there we can also
process our up votes and down votes on
multiple different kafa qes because we
know that the comment that they're going
to be on already exists in our different
comment indexes that being said again
writing things synchronously involves
some sort of transaction and if it's a
distributed transaction that's even
worse it's just a lot of locks to grab
it's really going to slow down wres and
that's not something that we want so
here I'm going to illustrate those two
solutions which again I now realize are
both bad and hence I've made a third one
right after this so don't focus on this
one too hard imagine we have our source
of Truth comments database imagine we
have our upvotes database one possible
solution like I mentioned is to just put
everything in the same cofa Q via change
data capture all of which is going to be
partitioned on post
ID and then that goes into flank and
then Flink is going to update our
derived views accordingly cool that
seems easy enough right so the main idea
here is that you know all of our up
votes are coming in as like a user and
then a comment
ID and on Flink we would just be
aggregating those for counts for comment
ID you know comment one has 10 comment
two has 20 and that's just going to
reduce the number of rights that we
actually have to make to each of our
derived views so that's going to be
useful for us
cool again though it is possible we have
too much data for one kof Q to handle
because we're Shing by post IDs there
are a lot of up votes and a lot of down
votes what could be better is if we
actually just first wrote all of the
comments to both our source of truth
table and the derived views and then
this way we can have our upvotes
database go not just through one kofka q
but potentially to multiple different
cof's thus balancing the
load have multip different Flint
consumers you know this time now we're
sharting on comment ID as opposed to
post ID which is more granular so this
is all comment
ID and then we're going to go ahead and
finally upload all of those counts to
our derived
views again like I mentioned this part
problematic because that is a right to
four places at once we don't like to
have to do that that's
bad so what does Jordan do instead well
he goes ahead and makes something that
is completely over complicated that he
loves so what does it look like well
basically what we're going to do is this
we have our comments database we
mentioned there are probably not going
to be that many comments for a
particular post up to a million but
they're probably going to be relatively
sparse in terms of when they're being
made it's not like a million per second
so again we have our comment database
all of those comments are flooding into
Kafka sharded on a post ID so that
they're all going to the same Flink node
in Flink we're just going to do the
following take in a comment put in our
derived comment views over
here where these comment views are the
ones for top controversial and hot the
next thing that we're going to go ahead
and do is basically say oh you know what
I just received an incoming
comment we're going to take that comment
ID we're going to throw it in this queue
over here which is sharded on post ID
and comment ID so basically we're going
to take our post ID and comment ID that
just came into Flink on the comments
path and put it into the upvotes
path so now the thing to note is that
again post ID and comment ID is far more
granular this is going to be handling
far fewer events rather than a Kofa q
that is sharted by just post ID and has
to handle all of those uploads for a
given post now what we can do is say
okay let's say comment
one uh comment one has you know 150 up
votes however we're also keeping track
of whether comment one is present or not
and we'll know when it's present because
it actually just comes through this
kofka Q it's present because it's been
processed by Flink goes through the
kofka Q and flows into spark streaming
so we're actually not going to go ahead
and upload our up uh our up vote counts
to our derived views until comment one
makes its way to spark streaming so
basically once it does we see it we say
true now we have code that says oh you
know what the comment is present we can
go ahead and upload these guys to spark
streaming and now we're causally
consistent because we're only uploading
the upvotes once the comment actually
exists in all of these derived comment
views because the first thing that we do
is put the comment in the derive comment
views and then we put the comment in
Kafka to go down to spark streaming
hopefully that makes sense it's a bit
convoluted I know but it does work and
you know the stream processing and
actual determinism of all these stateful
consumers makes our life pretty easy
when getting this done
cool the last question or last thing to
talk about before I really uh go into
the full on design is the upvotes
database so this is a component that I
kind of glossed over right here we have
our comment database which I spoke about
plenty already that's just our source of
Truth datab datase but the upvote
database what is that well upvotes are
pretty simple in terms of their schema I
would think that uh basically you would
say okay here's our user field here's
our post field here's our comment ID
field and then here's whether it was an
up Vote or a down
vote so that's going to be our database
schema and the nice thing about that is
that now all of a sudden as long as we
Shard by our user ID and our post ID for
a given post if I'm a user and I load
that post I can really quickly see all
of the IDS of comments that I've
uploaded and so my client can quickly
show me whether or not I've uploaded
them which is going to be very useful
now of course like I mentioned uh this
alone is not going to basically store
all of the counts of up votes and down
votes on each comment that's why we have
this whole convoluted change data
capture thing right over here so that we
can aggregate the counts in spark
streaming and then upload them
accordingly both to our derived views
and also similarly to our actual source
of Truth comment database we want to
denormalize the comment counts uh
otherwise we're going to have to do a
massive distributed query to figure out
how many users have actually uploaded a
given comment and that would be very
slow and of course it's okay if this is
eventually consistent or you know it
takes a while to get the right count it
doesn't really matter I don't care if a
comment has a th000 up votes or 1,1 up
votes cool so going back here again the
main idea is we want to be sharding by
the user ID and the post ID so that when
I load a given post I can quickly find
all the comments that I've uploaded or
that I have downvoted now the main idea
from here is that then we would use the
change data capture from these tables
and then these can go into kofka and
flank or Kafka and Spark streaming
whatever you want to do and you
basically would just aggregate those
into the up vote and down vote score per
comment the point is as opposed to
sharding by the user ID and the post ID
ID of every up vote and down vote in
that Kafka Q we would actually Shard on
the post ID and the comment ID so that
we can do easy aggregation in our
stateful consumer that is going to make
a lot more sense so that we can have all
of those up votes and down votes on a
single node for a single comment of a
single post
great sorry this is getting so
convoluted makes sense to me we'll see
if it makes sense for you guys the next
aspect of this is my obligatory caching
Slide the reason I'm doing this is
because if you were to do an interview
about Reddit comments and you didn't at
some point mention caching you would
probably be in trouble I don't really
want to talk about it but I'm going to
do it anyway the idea here is pretty
simple uh for a lot of hot posts or or
just for posts in general uh you
probably want to cash some initial
comments right maybe the first 10 of the
top view the new view the hot View and
the controversial view so that the first
time someone clicks over to one of those
we can load that up really quickly uh
and you can either you know pre push
that into our cache or you can just do
uh you know a write around cache where
we first write over here then we attempt
to read right we get a cash Miss and
then it loads the data into our cach
such that now we're populated so those
are a couple of valid options and again
like I mentioned ideally we've got
basically the first view of the new the
hot the controversial and the uh the top
comments for a given post and then
another client side optimization that we
can in theory do is you know if there
are a few different buttons to load more
comments once we've uh loaded that first
set of comments we could begin to
prefetch the next set of comments uh
before we even click that button but
that's you know that's for a whole
different interview maybe a front-end
one who knows cool um I also think that
right back commenting is probably not
the move here or right back hashing uh
even though it would speed up the rights
a one we care a lot more about reads and
B is that we want everything to
ultimately go through our change data
capture and so in order for it to do
that it needs need to First go into our
database so we definitely want to be
writing to the database we could do a
write through cache uh but I just don't
think we care about cash consistency
that much um I feel like right back
right rather right around is the the
clear win
here cool and then finally right before
my voice gives out on me we're going to
be doing a final overview of the design
I'm going to go very slowly here
hopefully uh it is going to make
everything that I've poorly explained
throughout the video a little B bit more
understandable okay so the first aspect
of this is going to be our comment
service when I write a comment it goes
through there and the first place that
it goes to is our source of Truth
database like I mentioned the nice thing
about our source of Truth database is
that it incidentally serves as a good
index for the new comments effectively
it's just the exact opposite of new con
uh comments older comments are going to
come first in that source of Truth
database like I mentioned um it would be
nice to have neo4j here because we
sometimes want to be able to run
arbitrary queries and just get comments
with a given ID uh if we wanted to run a
breath first search sometimes as opposed
to a depth first search uh using a
typical index is not going to be very
good for us so of course here we want
this entire graph on the same node
otherwise we're going to be in for a
world of pain doing a bunch of
distributed reads so in order to achieve
that we should probably make it so that
all of our com all of our comments are
shed by their post ID so for a single
post we want those all on the same table
the next aspect of this is going to be
Kafka once I write a comment to the
source of Truth database I don't want to
synchronously update all of our derived
comment indexes but I do want to do it
eventually we throw that comment in
Kafka so that we can process it later
this should be a relatively quick write
and can be achieved through change data
capture we're going to Shard Kafka on
our post ID so that all of the comments
for a given post can be handled by the
same instance of Flink cool from there
what Flink is going to do is basically
do a batch right to all of the derived
data sources our top comments view our
controversial View and our hot View and
basically what this is is really just
writing the uid or the ID of the comment
to those places and inserting them into
the graph there so that's going to be
step one of this and then once it gets
those acknowledgements step two is going
to be putting it in the Kafka Q to
eventually be acknowledged by the spark
streaming upload
counter so I would say this guy is
responsible for counting not uploads but
rather up
votes cool upvotes counter so again the
nice thing about this kfaq is that it is
going to be sharded on the post ID and
the comment ID so it actually doesn't
matter anymore if your comment is uh the
same post is another comment all that we
really care about is making sure that
for a given comment it and all of it up
votes and down votes are on the same
instance of spark streaming and beyond
that we do not care in that same vein we
also be uh we want to make sure that all
of the upvotes on a particular comment
are going to be on the same spark
streaming node so all that we have to do
is from our upot table over here we can
very quickly upload those to Kafka again
Shard on the post ID and the comment ID
and then basically group those up right
so over here I would say oh you know
comment one
has a score of plus 10 and have we seen
it yes we have now we can go ahead and
throw that in all of these different
indexes and upload and rather uh update
the edge score right there and possibly
reorder them due to that right cool the
reason I also say spark streaming here
is I think mini batching could be good
we don't want to do an upload to all of
our derived indexes on every single up
Vote or down vote but rather we want to
get a bunch at a time aggregate them and
then change the count notes over there I
haven't yet gone through uh the upvotes
table the reason the upvotes table is my
SQL is because the data model is very
simple I don't need any sort of uh graph
database or anything like that all I
really care about is that for a given
user and a given post ID I can really
quickly figure out what comment IDs
they've actually upvoted or downvoted
hence we shred on the user ID and the
post ID and of course when we actually
do make an up Vote or down vote that
actually just goes right here through
our up vot service the last aspect of
this whole thing is that we're going to
go ahead and eventually read comments
and when we do the main thing that we
want to be doing is reading them first
through potentially one of these views
right so let's say I wanted to read the
top comments for a given post I would go
to the top deriv data cache this would
give me a list of comment
IDs comment ID and then after I get my
list of comment IDs I would go right
over to the source of Truth database I
would fetch those and then I would have
them return to me through the comment
cache which is probably just going to be
redus we can Shard that by our post ID
and then of course uh the idea here is
that we just want to use lru right so as
that thing gets filled up we just throw
out the least recently used entry cool
guys uh this was a lot longer than I was
expecting it to be my throat is killing
me I want to go to bed I imagine you all
do too but uh it's been real thank thank
you guys for all the support on this
channel uh you keep me going every day
with it and uh I'm really enjoying doing
it so let's keep up the great work see
you guys soon